happy birthday thank you yes
thirty-eight again me too oh yeah it's
good isn't it feels nice being only 38
what did you do to celebrate I had
dinner with my wife and we we celebrated
her getting two Reuters journalists out
of prison in Myanmar that happened to be
like 8 o'clock last night so it was a
big deal that's impressive I was like
just expecting like cake or something
but that's that's way better it's a big
one I mean honestly well it's amazing
cuz she spent the last year pretty much
every day of working on this and so to
have that happen was a big day speak
like a proud hubby I like it yeah that's
fine I thought maybe you actually called
up Harry and Megan and said can you have
the baby born on my birthday well I was
a little irritated cause that kid really
is stealing my thunder just a little bit
but that's okay Nancy come on man this
is my date I was sharing it already with
Orson Welles and Sigmund Freud and now
they now you got the royal baby yeah
named after you or something oh good
idea there's an already one called
George you know like George the second
or cousin or whatever how that works
Wow she's a real royal whisperer yeah
you doing his daddy they're good they're
fat what do you feed them everything
yeah this is keep them quiet you just
feed him did you call up Meghan her here
and give him a little fatherly advice
yeah you're stuck on this Meghan
everything Oh baby's a big deal I see I
see
along with catch-22 it all works
together you see oh she's bringing that
in yeah I know you're friendly I
actually didn't call people who've never
had children for advice about my
children no I meant to give them no I
don't give advice I'm 58 you spoke to
him
I mean at 58 literally you just it stops
just go everything just goes downhill
just walk with a walker everywhere I go
you probably wished him well of course
sure I'm very happy they're lovely
couples so it's exciting read me back
the last line bring me back the last
line not my last line somebody else
bring me back the last line that's my
last line again oh no sir that's my last
line I read it to you just a moment ago
so congratulations that show is awesome
yeah thanks we're really proud
and chris is amazing and Chris Abbott
you got George Clooney walking up on the
carpet behind you there who you know
that little movie star named George
Clooney oh yeah he seems nice he does
right he's not so nice at this TV show
though he's like angry in the seniors in
catch-22 one yeah he is he's an angry
guy in this one you know but you need a
balance everyone's used to George being
so charming and awesome and now you know
be mean exactly so I mean he was
director and executive producer was he
ever mean at all I mean even the
slightest inkling on the set you know he
doesn't I don't know if he has one of
those bones in his body you know he can
be a bit of a jokester a bit but it's
always it's always fun you know it's a
it is always fun thank you and I are the
only two sane people on this base so
you're very angry in the show you notice
yeah like you really got a lot out I got
a lot of anger out it's like it's that
or a therapist so I just did that and
stay you can make money at the same I
could do that exactly get paid and get
therapy
do you ever though cuz you know always
asking all the the guys that you were
directing and stuff they're like he
never gets mad but whoever is there ever
a moment that you really just kind of
let loose I don't tell them but then I
go back in the trailer and I'd kick
things after they screw up now I
honestly you know you and I both get to
do the jobs we love what's it to be mad
about most people have to work for a
living and we don't have to we get to do
stuff we love it's gotta be some little
something that makes you mad nothing
nothing I'm not mad at anything I got a
beautiful wife I got two knuckleheads
four kids
you know everybody is talking about this
being a your because we love you on TV
we love you anywhere you know because we
love towards Clooney but it's funny I've
been doing television all along but you
know remember the biggie our farewell
like I said this is kind of it so what
was it that brought you back like what
you were saying okay I'll do this I
thought it was a really good script I
thought was a really good time to I
think it's always a good time to talk
about the absurdity of war I don't think
that ever gets old and I thought this
was a proper place to do it so I was
excited
and your executive producer and you're
also director see the boss that's right
I know Bruce sting sting forget it I'm
the boss
I want to see
[Music]